the new year starting in just a few days
our series what's new in 22 takes a
closer look at stories and trends that
will define the next year ahead this
morning we will focus on travel an
industry that has faced restrictions
cancelled trips destination closures and
job losses over the past year cbs news
senior travel advisor peter greenberg
looks at what to expect in 2022 and how
to prepare good morning peter how are
you doing
i'm hanging in nate
we're all hanging in there just before
the new year so hang in here with us
just for a minute um thousands of
flights were canceled this holiday
weekend um and that's due to rise in
covet cases and of course staffing
shortages what are airlines doing to
combat this and also uh you know will
this get worse as we approach the new
year
well they are trying to pare down their
schedules of course weather is always
the intangible but remember they're all
trying to just get through this week
because if they can get to january 4th
fares plummet traffic plummets and they
can get back on track let me give you an
example if i wanted to book a round-trip
ticket this morning from new york to los
angeles assuming i could even get on a
plane that round trip fare is 700
january 5th
132
i also priced out a dallas to new york
trip on january 5th it was 32
the cab ride to the airport is more
expensive so remember if they can get to
the first quarter that's when traffic
drops historically very few people
travel in the first quarter and that's
what they're hoping to do in the
meantime they pulled out of a number of
cities americans pulled out of 26 cities
delta and united about 10 cities each so
they're trying to get back to a more
stable schedule
peter here's something that a lot of
people want to know will airlines start
to mandate vaccines for passengers
well there's some precedent for this in
canada right now you cannot get on an
airplane unless you can show proof of
vaccination the same is in place in
australia a number of the ceos that i've
talked to in this country want
desperately to have that rule but no one
airline wants to take the lead because
they're worried about losing market
share they're waiting for the biden
administration to make that rule they're
not about to make that rule right now
because their other vaccination mandate
is being challenged in the courts all
the way up to the supreme court so until
that's resolved it's dead on arrival
peter you really probably can't see this
but the guys can i have more than 600
000 sky miles i need to use i know a lot
of people have frequent flyer miles
especially if they have been traveling
during the pandemic what should i be
doing with these and why redeem them now
jamie you want to run not walk to redeem
those miles i'm giving you all a red
flag warning here because during the
pandemic the airlines were desperate to
raise cash
and what did they realize their frequent
flyer programs were actually worth more
than the airlines themselves and they
actually mortgaged their programs for
between six and 10 billion dollars each
airline that's a lot of debt how they
going to handle that debt they're going
to start devaluing your miles they're
making it harder to earn them and harder
to redeem them so what you want to do is
start today look out about 330 days as
far out as that and redeem miles as much
as you can because starting in january
that devaluation parade is going to
start and it's not going to be pretty
oh so peter speaking of value you say we
should expect to pay more for hotels in
the new year but that rates will be
negotiable
who are they what are these hotel brands
that will negotiate rates uh because
i've never had that experience tell me
how to do it
oh the reason why you haven't had that
experience is chances are you made your
reservations online you need to have a
conversation remember it's the law of
supply and demand
it's not the posted rate that counts
it's all the ancillary rates about
whether you're not going to have to pay
for the water or the wi-fi or the
parking and not only that as more hotels
open with the same continuing staff
shortages it's going to be a much more
competitive marketplace they'll be much
more willing to negotiate because any
revenue is better than no revenue
all right so how do you expect
the restaurant business
to have an impact on what's going to
happen in 2022
well you'd expect to pay more for your
for your menu every menu item price is
going up and a lot of things that never
used to be on the menu as a charged item
they're going to be on that remember
they have staffing issues that are going
to continue through the first quarter
they're going to only way to get they're
going to get their people back is do
what incentivize them
higher wages perks benefits and that's
going to all translate into higher menu
prices not just on the entrees but what
used to come on your dish is now going
to be charged as a side order even the
bread basket is going to be a paid item
so be prepared for that what oh no
the bread and butter has always been
free
you just ruined my morning now i'm
joking uh peter greenberg thank you so
much you're awesome with valuable
information that we need